you just care so much amanda  you just can't help yourself  i should go  well  this is dangerous  we've had wine  yes  let's go wreck-it ralph principal's  office now  oh you better get your finger on my face  you don't point at me i'm the biggest  burner you have seen  that's so stupid so childish looking  come at me bro  okay  well your hands are far too delicate for  real scream shot work and i happen to be  a charter subscriber to middling warlord  weekly so i'd recognize you i'm gonna go  with c  and you  who are you  what's he doing up there  big paradise  no one else came up snake guys but us  lord's protection we got it don't we boy  yes sir we gotta sir  don't mow them [ __ ] down didn't he  too  hey good job welcome to the army norm  you did good  best job ever